If you use the app and then you select two dice, you might notice that this
scale goes from two to twelve and that's because this app sums up the two rolls.
But this is still the same concept because when you take the average, you sum up
the two rolls and then you just divide by two. So, the distribution will look
exactly the same pretty much as what is shown here. Except the scale will just
be these numbers divided by two. But the important thing is that the shape of
the distribution will be the same. So let's roll 2 dice once. So we get that the
sum is 9, which means that the average would be 4.5. If we roll again we would
get that the average is 3 and the sum is 6. And we can keep doing this a number
of times and you see that the more we roll the dice and plot the distribution of
the sums or the averages, it looks more and more normal. Play around with this
applet because it's a really good learning tool.